Good morning, Hank, it's Monday. I love Brazil!
Did you know that Brazilian Nerdfighters petitioned
Brazilian publishers to publish LOOKING FOR
ALASKA in Portuguese and it totally worked?
God, I love Brazil. Hank, today I want to
tell you about Brazil and the United States
that I first heard on the amazing podcast
"Planet Money" -- there's a link to that below
-- But I also have to do some errands today
so ... walk with me.
So, Hank, this tee-shirt -- and yes, I'm wearing
my face on my torso -- is made from 100% American
cotton, like almost all cotton tee-shirts
in the world. Why? Because the United States
massively subsidizes its cotton industry.
Alright I've gotta get a water filter for
my fridge. Let's drive.
The U.S. spends more than three billion dollars
a year on its cotton subsidy, which has the
effect of making the price of American cotton
artificially cheap. That's a bit of an over-simplification,
but in my defense, I'm currently driving on
snow.
Right, so these cotton subsidies don't just
make American cotton cheap in America, they
make American cotton cheap everywhere, which
is why the U.S. is by far the world's largest
exporter of cotton. That's great for the American
cotton farmer, but it kinda sucks for all
the non-American cotton farmers. It also sucks
for those of us who are Americans who aren't
cotton farmers, because all we get for that
3.1 billion dollars in taxes is, like, slightly
cheaper tee-shirts.
Must resist urge to eat cheeseburgers!
So, Hank, under international trade agreements,
some agricultural subsidies are legal, but
you're not allowed to artificially lower the
price of something; and in 2002 Brazil filed
a case with the W.T.O. saying basically, when
it comes to cotton,
Americans are a bunch of cheating cheaters
of cheatery.
And their illegal cotton subsidies have made
it completely impossible for Brazilian farmers
to compete, even to sell cotton IN BRAZIL,
because American cotton is so artificially
cheap.
In 2004 the W.T.O. sides with Brazil, says
American cotton farming subsidies are completely
illegal. Whereupon the United States says,
"We're rubber, you're glue; W.T.O. rulings
bounce off us and stick to you."
Holy snood! Adulthood is expensive.
We completely refuse to comply, just keep
appealing, and appealing, and finally in 2008
we lose our last appeal, whereupon we're like,
"Ya know what? Nah, we're not gonna comply."
Which we can totally do because it turns out
there's no actual penalty for failing to follow
trade agreements. We gotta go to the grocery
store.
So after the U.S. failed to abide by the W.T.O.'s
decision that U.S. cotton subsidies were illegal,
Brazil's only real recourse was retaliation.
But if you're a small economy in a fight with
a huge economy, your retaliation options are
a little limited. Like, if Liberia doesn't
like American cotton subsidies, they can say,
"You know what? We're gonna tax all American
imports to Liberia."
And then America will be like, "... Okay."
And that's probably how this fight with Brazil
would have ended ten years ago, but what happened
in the meantime is that Brazil became a BIG
economy. Nowhere near the size of the U.S.,
certainly, but big.
Which is why, when Brazil threatened to tax
American imports like pharmaceuticals and
cosmetics, those companies called their friends
in the American government and said, "Ya gotta
do something about this cotton business!"
And they did come to an agreement! In April
of 2010 the United States announced that it
would pay Brazilian cotton farmers 147 million
dollars a year in order to continue subsidizing
our own cotton farmers illegally, to the tune
of three billion dollars a year.
And that, Hank, is how the United States came
to subsidize the Brazilian cotton industry.
If we were gonna be fair, we should subsidize
every cotton industry in the developing world,
but Brazil was the only country that was smart
enough to sue us and big enough to scare us.
Like I said earlier, I love Brazil. But I
don't want to send their cotton farmers 147
million dollars each year.
Hank, I'll see you on Wednesday.
By the way, Nerdfighters, the American taxpayer
has already paid for a significant portion
of this tee-shirt. If you'd like to pay for
the rest of it, you can do so at dftba.com/pizza
It's in stock, ships immediately, and thanks
to bad economic policy-making, it's only $18.